foreign
[Music]
briefing it's Tuesday June 13th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
the Federal Trade Commission has sought
a temporary restraining order to block
Microsoft from buying video game
publisher Activision Blizzard for 75
billion dollars the regulator has said
the deal would give Microsoft too much
control over the gaming industry the
order still needs a judge's approval to
prevent the companies from finalizing
the deal next month with me to discuss
this is our reporter Dave Michaels who
covers Financial enforcement Dave this
isn't the first step that the FTC has
taken to block Microsoft's purchase of
Activision so what's gone down so far
well the FTC previously back in December
filed a formal challenge
of the transaction in what is called
administrative core which is
a special in-house court that the
Federal Trade Commission has to
adjudicate matters like disputed mergers
and Acquisitions so why has it taken
this latest step well when the FTC first
challenged the Microsoft Activision deal
there didn't appear to be the urgency at
the time for the FTC to go into court
and ask a federal judge to Grant a
restraining order or an injunction that
would halt the companies from closing it
looked like the companies were going to
allow the government investigations or
lawsuits to play out and see who won
before they closed but time has passed
and Microsoft Activision has cleared
review in a bunch of jurisdictions
including the European Union
and conditions have changed a little bit
so the FTC has apparently judged that
they need to go into court and seek an
order that would stop the deal from
closing so that it could get through
that in-house proceeding and where do
things stand with that in-house
proceeding have they started yet well
you can kind of just think of it as a
lawsuit and the papers are flying back
and forth but the hearing is not
scheduled until August
so that hearing in August will take time
and then it'll take the judge a while to
issue a decision his decision could
actually then be appealed you mentioned
that the deal has received some approval
and other jurisdictions including the
European Union but it was also rejected
by the UK so where do things stand for
these companies when it comes to this
tie up they're still in dispute with
governments in the United States the
United Kingdom so it isn't clear that
they can close right now because if they
did close that could have consequences
for the business in the UK so it just
looks like this deal is continuing to go
through litigation it's going to be a
while before we have any certainty about
it in the United States and perhaps even
longer in the United Kingdom and
Microsoft said they look forward to
presenting the case in federal court so
one advantage if you will for Microsoft
is that in federal court if the company
defeats the FTC it is likely then that
the FTC may drop the in-house proceeding
so the federal court proceeding will
happen on a faster timetable
and if Microsoft prevails and the judge
says no I'm not going to issue an
injunction because I do not believe that
this deal right now looks to be illegal
that would be bad for the ftc's theory
for why it challenged the deal so in a
sense getting into federal court could
provide some clarity about this deal
sooner for Microsoft at least in the
United States all right that's our
reporter Dave Michaels
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]